círculos perfectos de verdor para ser
regados granjas gigantescas de casi
20.000 cabezas de ganado para ser
regadas y kilómetros de nueces pecán
para hacer irrigadas la casa de carolina
camp son una vendedora a domicilio está
rodeada de granjas un pozo de su única
fuente de agua potable
soy harvard tenía unos 25 metros de agua
y ahora están 6 metros de estatura
el pozo quedó casi seco en un año
todavía tiene agua para unas pocas
semanas más pero necesitaría un pozo más
profundo
así que va a costar más de 20 mil o 30
mil dólares es mucho dinero no creo que
pueda hacerlo desde el punto de vista
declaró implica que en duelo el agua
está monopolizada por la agricultura
frente a la casa de marks spencer un
ingeniero consultor está en estos
círculos de alfalfa una hierba animal el
pozo de la granja está enfrente de su
casa
hay un cultivo aquí y otro allá así que
este pozo probablemente bombea de 700 a
10.000 galones por minuto es decir mil
millones de galones por minuto
hay muchas nuevas granjas si un montón
de nuevas granjas
en el sur de arizona en cinco años la
tierra cultivada ha aumentado en un 30%
100 wilcox el número de pozos pasó de 43
a 123 esto es uno de los equipos de
perforación impresionante
vamos a perforar tres mil a 3700 metros
las granjas se establecen porque no hay
límite para el bombeo de agua
subterránea
en esta área no hay ninguna
reglamentación
y sus clientes pueden perforar lo que
quieran los clientes pueden perforar un
pozo cada tres metros no hay
sin impuestos nada no
el agua es gratis ser propietario de la
tierra significa tener acceso limitado
al recurso y las granjas quieren pozos
profundos invierten mucho dinero en
estas granjas y estos pozos los
inversores quieren asegurarse de que
haya mucho dinero en ella durante mucho
tiempo ninguna de las granjas a las que
nos acercamos quería abrir sus puertas
así que es a los rancheros a los que
vamos a conocer los hermanos contienen
tres mil cabezas de ganado explotan
estas tierras desde hace mucho tiempo y
también se oponen a cualquier regulación
[Música]
somos dueños de la tierra somos dueños
del agua como la gente de aquí en
realidad queremos ser dueños de lo
nuestro no queremos que la gente nos
diga lo que tenemos que hacer y nos
gusta tener la propiedad como la tenemos
porque si no tenemos control sobre el
agua entonces no tenemos nuestra tierra
y gabbana realidad están los hermanos
cuan preocupados de estar algún día sin
agua por culpa de las grandes granjas no
en realidad no explican que no serán los
primeros en quebrar
incluso las grandes corporaciones y se
quedan sin agua se van a la quiebra
eso es como cualquier cosa así funciona
el capitalismo así que si se van a la
quiebra
adiós desde es el robo frente a esta
resistencia cuál es el estado del
suministro de agua en arizona cerca de
phoenix nos encontramos con los técnicos
de la agencia de aguas aquí toman
muestras pero los volúmenes bombeados
son desconocidos en unos dos tercios del
estado es esta la zona de administración
activa ama de santa cruz está la ama de
tucson la ama de philips la ama de
frescos el resto del estado no está mal
la agencia no tiene acceso a los pozos
ubicados en propiedad privada como en el
caso de las granjas para éste hidrólogo
el nivel freático era alarmante
la precipitación natural no reemplaza el
agua bombeada con la suficiente rapidez
por eso tenemos una disminución del
nivel del agua freático de 30
centímetros a 3 metros cada el nivel
baja cada vez más eso significa que en
algún momento el agua se agotará
marks spencer nos muestra estas enormes
grietas en el suelo cerca de las granjas
[Música]
la tierra está colapsando junto con el
nivel del agua y eso es solo una grieta
plaza y por todo el condado
pero los políticos de aquí no tienen
intención de restringir la actividad
agrícola que es una industria de 23
millones de dólares al año en arizona